je voudrais vous rappeler que comme vous
le savez au 31 octobre les contrats
d'électricité de gaz se termineront pour
de nombreuses collectivités
territoriales et les nouveaux contrats
devront être signés au premier novembre
c'est à dire dans quelques jours sous
peine de coupure totale
ces régions ces départements ces villes
devront donc acheter l'électricité et le
gaz au prix du marché dans un contexte
dans un contexte de flambé débris de
l'énergie de nombreux élus locaux vous
ont d'ailleurs
alerté sur ce point chez nous en
Seine-Saint-Denis on nous annonce des
prix tout à fait insupportables une
multiplication par 15 des prix du gaz 32
du prix d'électricité en
Seine-Saint-Denis comme partout en
France une commune moyenne passerait
donc de 2 à 15 millions d'euros en
termes de dépenses d'énergie
comme vous en avez pris l'habitude
lorsqu'il s'agit des collectivités
territoriales et des élus locaux votre
réponse n'est pas à la hauteur monsieur
le ministre le ministre des comptes
publics a proposé une aide 438 millions
d'euros largement insuffisante s'il
avait s'il avait ouvertement souhaité
affiché son mépris pour les mères il ne
s'y serait pas pris autrement
surtout cette aide de s'appliquera qu'au
commune dont l'épargne brute c'est
fortement dégradé ces dernières années
comme d'habitude vous avez choisi de
sanctionner d'abord les bons élèves les
communes qui gèrent correctement
l'argent de leurs administrés
monsieur le ministre vous demandez
beaucoup d'efforts aux collectivités aux
entreprises aux Français vous avez
demandé aux salariés de porter des cols
rouler dans les bureaux vous avez
demandé aux écoliers de greloter dans
les salles de classe les Français ont
consenti beaucoup d'efforts ils ont
constitueront ils ont consentiront
encore mais ils ne doivent pas être les
seuls à consentir ces efforts monsieur
le ministre que répondez-vous aux
nombreux maires qui le savent pas
aujourd'hui
comment ils feront face à la flambée des
prix de l'énergie doivent-ils sacrifier
les services à la population pour payer
leurs factures de gaz et d'électricité
[Applaudissements]